what makes you an artist I think to be
an artist is to create you have to
finish something you have to you know
cuz you can toil away but I feel like
until it's out in the world it is it art
I don't know it's a tree falling in the
forest but yeah I think it's the
creation for me you know to created it
and put it out that's the art you're an
artist now what do you think makes
someone an artist is that a different
thing for you do you think I mean a lot
of people say they're artists or they're
writers and there's like this debate
well if you're not getting paid for it
are you really an artist are you really
a writer oh yeah um no I don't think he
need to be paid for it I mean throughout
history I think you know people had to
have patrons they had to the king had to
commission your portrait and that's the
only way you're going to eat and so you
do certain type of art to make sure that
you can eat and then you do your own art
in the back burner you know I do my own
movies and I work for others and
sometimes I'm more invested in the
project than not you know like I shoot
interviews like this for people for
corporate stuff um I want it to be good
I want it to look nice but it's not like
my art that's a job you know and so I
always make sure I have my artistic
things that are coming from my brain
more also always going you know even
though I enjoy like I enjoy being in AC
where I don't have any control over what
is the image you know might get my
little once in a while you know you can
say well a tiny thing you know maybe
they take it maybe they don't but um you
know but I like I think it goes back to
being a band like I like being the bass
player sometimes I like being the lead
singer you know and it's like figuring
out where you fit into those spots on
whatever project you're on is really
important and making sure you don't step
out of the lane too far when you are in
a more supportive role um but yeah I
don't think you need to be paid for your
art to be considered an artist I think
when I meet people and I'm like that
person's an artist is because I think
they're a genius or I think they think a
little differently than everybody else
and that's like where it's coming out
you know it's like if you surprise me
with something if your humor's like a
little bit off or you know is there's
something new to what you're doing I'm
like that person's an artist did anybody
try to rein you in especially in high
school no I had very supportive parents
um they I was the youngest of four and
by a lot so I was mostly home with my
parents all the time you know like
everybody else was at College uh and
they you know there wasn't a lot of
money so it wasn't like you can go take
all these class class or you can go to
this Museum or whatever but like you
know they gave me their guitar from the'
60s and they gave me whatever art
supplies I wanted and I just sat in my
room and did whatever I wanted um and so
and they always were like just very
there was no pressure to go to college
there was I mean I think because maybe
we you know my sister was the first
generation in our family on either side
I think to go to college you know so it
wasn't like it was
like it something you had there was
nothing you had to do it was go live
your life enjoy it have fun my dad's
very proud that I got into music because
I think that's something he wanted to do
and you know and they're like very proud
that like I travel the world and I get
to create and I do all you I'm doing
what I want um so I think for them it
was just about if you're happy or you're
good and so they were like verbally very
supportive there wasn't like a lot of
monetary like go off to this you know
Academy or college and learn whatever
you want that wasn't there but like the
the do whatever you want Live Your Dream
go try to make happened that was 100%
there when you got to Boston did you see
other people that had come from
situations like yours or maybe they were
a little more cookie cutter and they
were rebelling against what families
wanted Boston's a funny Town cuz I
learned a lot about it once I got there
you know like obviously I knew Harvard
was there you know and but like there
are so many colleges there and cuz I
showed up at the age where I should have
been going to college I think everybody
just assumed that I was you know and so
you're with suddenly and especially I
hung around Harvard Square because
that's where the folk Club was that I
like to play at Club passim I got a job
at a record store right around the
corner so I was in Harvard Square all
the time and people just started to
assume I went to
Harvard because I was just always there
you know but no and so you meet people
and especially like I think people that
from money don't want to ever tell you
that they're from money you know they
want to seem like they're on your level
of poverty and they are not you know and
you learn that later you know that they
had more opportunity all along than you
did or whatever you know but at that in
that playground you're the same for a
minute you know um so yeah so I think in
Boston especially it's a very rich white
City that like you know people had like
more support of stuff um but there's
also a huge underground art community of
people like me you know that came from
nothing and just want to make weird
stuff and it's very like um experimental
people doing cool stuff where does the
inspiration for your art come from oh
boy um
that's a hard question I know I'm not
sure you know I just get ideas and go
down paths you know the paths tend to
reveal themselves you know as you start
working on something like often with our
films like we have a script or whatever
and then once we get into production
like it kind of takes a different route
you know
um but yeah like I like things that are
surreal I like things out of the norm um
maybe it's more like dreamlike or more
Fantastical but not
fantasy don't like Wizards and Stu like
it's fine it's not that's not what I
mean by Fantastical just stuff that's
like more dreamlike I guess is you know
where the plane that I'm trying to pull
from um you know I love very colorful
cinematography so I love like 1970s
movies from everywhere but especially
like Italian Gio like they were not
playing by any rules any 3A structure
none of that mattered it was like were
the lights cool was it dreamy um um and
maybe I don't know if some of it is like
me viewing it 50 years later and this is
just what the 60s and 70s looked like in
Italy you know but now in on film stock
and everything it just seems so dreamy
um so I just like stuff that's not
reality I don't care for reality or
drama like drama in the the movie genre
term at all like I don't want to see two
people having a relationship fight
unless there's like a monster or
something to make it because it's not
interesting to me and I think it's cuz
it goes back to me very very grounded
pragmatic person like I just don't want
to like I don't need to watch drama like
play out like I you know there's enough
of that in real life you know I don't
need to see real life on screen um I
think sometimes like when you're
shooting people are like oh that's not
realistic this light shouldn't be there
and I'm like but it's a movie it doesn't
if it looks good and it works for the
story like put the light there you know
let it be orange let it be blue like
whatever like you know we're creating
the world and for me that's the biggest
thing thing is create the mythology
create the world and then play in that
so growing up you weren't into the
notebook or wasn't your favorite movie
no no I uh we had a uh a not a a like
Mom and Pop video store in town and they
would do like $5 five bucks five days
and so like I would just be in the B
Movie section like any Roger Corman
movie I like realized like okay this is
going to be weird I'll watch that uh
action sci-fi
anything that was you know like Arnold
schinegger I was watching the weirder
sci-fi stuff um B movies the stuff like
yeah I was into like all that and not so
much like I think like Titanic was
really big when I was a kid you I did
see it but like did I care not really
you know you think art comes from Pain
yeah I think um for a lot of people you
know they won't create unless they're
depressed you know and I think certainly
with like my songw writing you know when
when I started out it was like these are
my complaints or these are the things
I'm depressed about or I'm I'm really
sad so I'm going to write a song about
that and as I got older and I got like
you know maybe more balanced in my life
and in my brain my chemicals you know in
my mind um that became less interesting
to me you know and so you know the songs
became more abstract or just about
conversations or whatever um but I think
for a lot of people they can't create
without that pain you know and I think
that's always in the background you know
I think to be a sensitive person and to
um need to express that and need to deal
with our emotions and deal with like how
we're responding to things I I
definitely think that always will come
out in art but does an artist that's
great necessarily have to have a tragic
life no I don't think so I think like I
think our brains do a lot of weird stuff
you know and I don't think they need to
necessarily have like PTSD or some
tragedy to pull from I think being being
alive is hard and getting through a day
is difficult and like that could be
plenty to pull from and do something
very creative and that touches other
people has anyone ever come to you for
advice on getting started being an
artist being a musician a
filmmaker
um I I think I get that question a lot
as like a woman like how do you start as
a woman in XYZ um and usually you know
it's like it's the same advice it's like
just go go do it you know go go start
something find your people find your
friends that also may have a camera or
may have whatever to bring into your
your creative soup um I think that's the
only cuz I'm such a Hands-On person
that's my only advice just go start you
know and it's getting easier and easier
like I won't ever shoot on an iPhone
knock on wood but it's there for people
that are begin getting like yeah get
your iPhone go do it figure out your
angles you know figure out what you
think makes a good cinematic IC image um
it's it's definitely getting easier to
just go and go and do it with LED and
and iPhones and stuff um but you know I
think it's like a Don't Be Afraid from
like the more from the art side you know
the technical side whatever you'll learn
it if if you have an aptitude for if you
want to or you'll find somebody that
knows it to help you um but from the art
side I think it's just don't be afraid
you know I know a lot of people and we
all deal with like imposter syndrome I
have a lot of friends that are like oh
but I don't want to release anything
because what if people say it's bad I'm
like what if they do like is like is
their opinion the thing that's going to
stop you like do your art and release it
you know and move like move on you know
um I never want to be like languishing
on the same project you know like I want
to do it let it get out and move on like
I'm ready to go on to the next thing by
the time the other thing is done I'm my
mind is like what else is new like I
always want to be working on the new
thing um which is like we were talking
about promotion like it makes promotion
hard cuz like by the time it's done like
I don't I want to do something else I
don't want to talk about this movie I
just wanted to get
out but yeah like for art I think it's
the creation and it's the release you
have to release it so you can move on so
you have to finish it and so when you
tell people or give advice whether it's
a male or female that they they it's
almost like they can't be they can't
really care what people think I guess is
is that is that kind of what it boils
well I think also too people are often
looking for like well what's the magic
for Success because it's obviously not
hard work you know what is what is your
secret what's your secret like
ingredient and it's like no the answer
is hard work so you don't want to do the
hard work you're not going to finish
anything you know and you can give
people all the advice in the world if
they're not going to work at it it's not
going to happen you know sure that's
really cool so when you were working at
this record store and everyone thought
you were going to school there but you
were really working out I that that's
its own movie right there yeah that I
mean that's a really cool and then I
think at one point somebody from Harvard
interviewed me for the magazine and that
even made and like I didn't say I went
that you know it's just like because I
was playing at the folk Club they were
like interviewing like people they
thought were interesting and like I
think the fact that I ended up in that
magazine like made it even more like oh
she's Harvard whatever um even though it
didn't say that in the article you know
it was just like in the Harvard magazine
um like for a while that was online it's
like this is like another tangent of
mine but the early internet is
disappearing and it's I like my I hate
that so much from an archival sense like
our whole lives of like Myspace any
articles written about me in the early
2000s that were on like boston.com or
whatever they're gone like maybe there's
archives somewhere but I don't even
think so like that first 20 years of the
Internet it's like you're never going to
be able to find it again it's really
disappointing um but for a while that
was something that would come up when
you Googled me was this article you know
right but yeah it was very high fidelity
in there like like we were so cool you
know or we thought we were like the
three of us that worked in that record
store you know one was the older guy
dyed his hair black he was in the bands
he was awesome my best friend at the
time also working at the record store um
so it was a fun couple years I was there
like almost three
years but the thing is you weren't a
student there so you had this other
perspective that would I would actually
make a great story if you ever I don't
know maybe people think their own story
is boring but I think I think be cool I
don't know Sophia I don't know it just
be neat and then just because the thing
is you you were you had this different
perspective I don't know I can't say
what you thought but just it just sounds
interesting but so if because it seems
like you're not afraid to try things
when people ask you you know well not
just how do I get started but you know
how do I whether it's crowdfunding or
whatever it is um how do you tell them
to kind of like Get
over expectations from what happens or
how people perceive it well I think a
lot of my thick skin came from music
initially because I'm used to getting
the reviews there you know and I got
every kind of review because I was doing
like Angry music I was screaming it
wasn't particularly melodic um it was
loud it was fast it was angry you know
and that's a kind of music that if you
like it you love it and if you don't
like it you're like you know and so you
know I got tons of bad reviews and it's
like I dealt with all that at like 18
you know and like I was getting these
reviews and so like I had to get over it
fast you know to keep working and so now
when people criticize whatever I'm doing
I'm like I'm the first to criticize my
movie I don't think anything I've done
is to my level of what I want to be
doing you know I want to get I want it
to be more perfect every time and so
like if you tell me something is wrong
with my movie I already know you like
when I read the reviews like yeah I
agree I don't think it stops the movie I
think it's still fine I think it's still
watchable I think it's still fun but
yeah I agree you know 99% of the time
they're not wrong you know um so I think
it's like letting any of those
criticisms that come come either from
critics or your friends or whatever like
you can't let that stop you you can
either like assess it see if there's
something to learn from it or disagree
like I think disagreeing is fine I think
focus groups aren't necessarily your
friend you know when you bring your
movie to people like what do you think
because like they're not going to
necessarily have the all the same
background information that you brought
into it and why you made those choices
as you do and so you know they're coming
up with their own things and like they
should do their own movie you know um so
yeah it's really just like a thick skin
like I don't you can say anything to me
at this point I've heard it you know and
I don't care I'm going to keep
moving